hallo ihr lieben wir machen heute eines
meiner favoriten angeboten nämlich
laugengebäck wir machen leckeren
laugenbrezel und zwar machen wir die
schwäbische art mich die bayerische die
es meiner meinung nach ein bisschen
einfacher also auch anfänger geeignet
und bei der lauge an sich zeige ich euch
gleich auch einen schönen trick und das
ganze geht generell superschnellen
einfach das heißt ihr müsst machen sich
auf zum bäcker gehen sondern können sich
ganz einfach selber zubereiten
für den teig benötigen wir mehr in einer
ausreichend großen schüssel außerdem
lauwarme milch und weiche butter 1 hilfe
würfel etwas zucker und salz und später
für unsere lauge benötigen wir natron
salz und außerdem noch mal grobes
meersalz der hefeteig geht's super
schnell und einfach wir benötigen auch
keine maschine dafür jetzt sehen uns
erstmal unser mehl und wenn hier eine
mulde bilden schieben das einmal an die
seite
und da gehen wir an unsere komplette
milch hinein die milch muss lauwarm sein
das ist ganz wichtig und sie darf auch
nicht zu heiß sein
[Musik]
als nächstes gehen wir in die lauwarme
milch unsere hilfe rein und ihr merkt
dass sich für frisches wenn sie richtig
schönen zerbröselt in eurem händen gehen
jetzt einmal rein anschließend noch
zucker als nährstoff dazu und dann
lassen wir das zehn minuten abgedeckt
stehen
natürlich muss man das ganze vorher auch
umrühren das ist ganz wichtig ihr merkt
auch dass die hefe in der lauf am
nächsten bisschen anfängt zu schwitzen
und sich das gut verbindet und ich
gibt's einmal gerne vom rand noch so ein
bisschen mehr drüber und dann denke ich
dass mit einem tuch ab und lasst das so
ungefähr zehn bis 15 minuten lang stehen
[Musik]
nach 15 minuten können wir deutlich
erkennen dass die hefe gearbeitet hat
durch die lauwarme milch und durch den
zucker und jetzt werden wir alles zu
einem teig vertreten dafür gebe ich noch
butter und salz und ich arbeite gerne
mit handschuhen könnte natürlich auch
ohne machen und das ganze solche so drei
bis vier minuten lang gemietet werden
[Musik]
so der teig ist fertig ist ein relativ
fester tag und ich geb dir jetzt zurück
in die schüssel mit ein wenig mehl damit
wir den später auch richtig schön
rausbekommen bedeckt ist auch noch mit
ein bisschen mehl und dann das
küchentuch wie darübergeben und jetzt
müssen wir das ganze ungefähr ein bis
eineinhalb schon gehen lassen bis sich
der teig verdoppelt hat es gleich nach
eineinhalb stunden ist der tag richtig
schön oft gar nicht zeigt euch mal und
dann nehmen wir ihn aus der schüssel
raus und werden erst mal in gleichmäßige
stücke teilen könnt ihr selber
entscheiden ob acht oder zehn je nachdem
wie groß die plätzchen werden sollen
[Musik]
ich habe meinen tag jetzt in acht
gleichmäßig große stücke geschnitten und
ich weg das jetzt noch mal ganz kurz
jedes teil hat bei mir so ungefähr 95
bis 100 gramm gewicht und dann könnt ihr
euch das so ein bisschen daran
orientieren und ihr könnt entweder den
eingeteilten teig sofort nehmen und zur
brezel weiter verarbeiten also den
strang quasi ausrollen oder er macht
sich formt erstmals kugeln aus dem teig
und dann räumt ihr das aus das ist
einfach so eine persönliche sache so wie
ihr das am besten können und jetzt zeige
ich euch wieder eine richtig schöne
brezel vom ich nehme jetzt mein tag der
muss auch nicht ruhen wir brauchen auf
der arbeitsfläche auch kein mehl und
kein öl und ich hab das mal gerne so ich
nehme mal die untere handfläche daraus
für mich meine kraft und es auszuräumen
ja hier halt ne genau und dann achte ich
darauf dass die mitte ein bisschen
dicker ist als die seiten die strenge
dürfen auch ruhig denn sein aber ich
zeige sich jetzt einfach mal
[Musik]
so den brotteig habe ich jetzt fertig
ausgerollt mein strang ist so ungefähr
55 bis 60 cm lang noch mal für euch
jetzt klein hinweist und jetzt nehmen
wir uns einfach die beiden enden
gehen sie einmal übereinander und
drücken sich hier wieder fest an und
dann habt ihr eure typische brezel form
[Musik]
und jetzt jetzt spannend meine brezeln
die habe ich alle geformt acht stück
habe ich herausbekommen und die jetzt
bereiten wir die lauge vor warum laugen
anführungsstrichen es ist keine
wirkliche lage denn eine löschung zu
hause selbst herzustellen kann sehr
gefährlich werden
deshalb habe ich jetzt hier eine
natronlaugenhaltige rhi markt gefunden
und das findet ihr da auch ganz einfach
gebe dass in landwasser lasst euch noch
einmal aufkochen und dann zeige ich euch
ist weitergibt
und das ist der vorteil an diesem rezept
ihr kind zu hause ganz einfach
nachmachen der bekommt nato in den
drogeriemarkt und in jeder apotheke
wichtig ist nur dass der topf
ausreichend hoch ist denn herbst gesehen
als ich das bein geschüttet hat es
direkt gesprudelt jetzt kocht dass
gerade ich lasse es auf höchster stufe
gebe da jetzt meinen teil hinein und
wichtig ist dass ihr euren teil den also
diesen brezel wirklich eine minute lange
drin ist und dann direkt auf euerbach
blick gibt
[Musik]
meine laugenbrezeln sind jetzt fast
fertig es fehlen noch zwei wichtige
schritte
wir sind hier auf einem backblech
wegstück haben auf ein backblech drauf
gepasst aber wie gesagt acht steht
bekommt ja aus dem teig raus und anders
als bei bayerischen bringt sind werden
jetzt hier in den bauch kleine schnitzer
ein gerät mit dem messer dann platzen
sie nicht selber auf sondern die bekommt
später dann nach dem backen ihre schöne
form
und jetzt fehlt nur noch ein
entscheidender schritt unser salz ich
liebe das kann ich genug sein für mich
es ist wirklich so an keiner bäckerei
gehen vorbei ohne dass ich mir einen
laugenstangen oder in den lauben brezel
mitnehme und jetzt gebe ich dann
reichlich von auf die brezeln
und ihr könnt das salz auch ruhig
richtig dran drücken in den teig und ich
habe den ofen übrigens auch schon vor
geheilt ist ganz wichtig dass der
vorgeheizt ist nämlich auf 180 grad ober
und unterhitze und dann gebe ich sie in
den backofen für ungefähr 20 bis 25
minuten ihr werdet merken diese farbe
und die kruste ihr werdet sehen wann sie
fertig sind nimmt einfach rechtzeitig
raus dass sie nicht zu trocken werden
[Musik]
und fertig sind die selbst gebackenen
brezeln und ganz ehrlich gesehen richtig
aus wie selbst gekauft vom bäcker ich
finde die unglaublich lecker wenn sie
noch laufen sind es liegen aber auch
gerne am nächsten morgen zum frühstück
mit ein bisschen frischkäse schnitt noch
obendrauf es gibt nichts besseres sage
ich euch und die genauen mengenangaben
die schreibe ich euch wie immer hier
unten in die infobox
ansonsten freue ich mich natürlich wenn
ihr diesen video in deutscher nach oben
gibt und fleißig sofort die glocke
aktiviert damit ihr auch kein video mehr
verfasst und was noch hansa und bilder
über den hashtag ist schon auf instagram
sendet richtig richtig schön da freue
ich mich immer total drüber
ja also ich springe die luft ehrlich
ansonsten freue ich mich wenn ihr misst
man auch wieder dabei sein auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]